Jennifer is in RK Jennifer welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey hey what's up
nothing much how are you I'm gonna make
it I'm better than I deserve
how can I help okay so my husband and I
been living with his parents for about
almost two years in January made for a
house
we finally have reached our goal of
50,000 in savings and we found this
really awesome house that for the list
price 230 but the house is worth 260
right um so we're getting a pretty good
deal on that but then we got hold on you
and the Total Money Makeover and we
started realizing like maybe we should
sit down and start to crunch out the
numbers and we have about sixty five
thousand dollars in debt 30 more
oh yeah of it is student loans and 31 of
it is about like credit cards and it's
negotiable so we kind of just sat
together and you looked at each other
and you're just like can we take this
money continue to live with her in-laws
for a few months pay off the debt be
completely debt-free but then have no
money for the down payment for a house
and have to start all over again so if
you did that would you go get an
apartment or something yeah so that's
what we were thinking if we pay down all
of our that 100% we would just rent for
a little while
well you said well you save up another
down payment yeah while we save for
another down payment yeah Hayate you've
had this dream of buying a house you've
even picked out the house yeah and
you've sacrificed to get there I mean
it's hard it's no small thing for me to
just sit here until you don't do that
but I got to tell you after 20 years 25
30 years now a financial coaching I if I
woke up in your shoes I would pay off
the debt before I bought a house right
oh really even if it's like a great deal
yeah there's no there's no deal great
enough because the problem is when you
buy a house with a bunch of debt hanging
around
neck and no money because you're gonna
put all your money into the house then
um you know Murphy moves in your spare
bedroom and brings his three cousins
broke desperate and stupid in your case
you got to buy an extra bedroom for
Salome right I mean she's got her own
place there so I it's been your dream
and I feel like I'm breaking your heart
but I'm really not because you're
grown-up people you're not children and
so you can make grown-up decisions that
I got through yeah you know I mean I
don't I'm not you know I'm not the holy
spirit that's that's his job but uh I
don't know if getting through to me as a
sign but but uh but I you know I will
tell you that if I woke up in your shoes
with all the experience I have under my
belt I know Jennifer that you guys are
going to get you a home and I know it's
going to be a nice home and I know two
years from now when you do that and
you've done it the right way you're
going to be glad you did it the right
way because stuff happens in life and if
you haven't absolutely no money you've
you know you've paid everything you
towards this house and got this debt
hanging around your neck it just all
kinds a bad crap can happen in your life
and it just I don't want you to invite
that and so I got to tell you if you
were my daughter it's exactly what I
would tell you to do and I know it's
painful but by far the wisest thing for
you to do is to pay this on the debt
finish paying off the debt as soon as
possible get you a little apartment get
you an emergency fund a three to six
months of expenses and then save you a
good strong down payment and get into a
home I would rather you do that and put
less down on the house than when you're
talking about now and and and do it
right without the debt hanging around
your neck so obviously you guys are
adults you're going to do what you want
to do but I have to tell you here on
this show it's what I would do is pay it
on the debt and then get your little
apartment
you